all right guys today I'm talking about
one of my favorite Sony TVs of 2023 this
is the a80l in the 77 inch variant and
also how the Sony HTA 7000 Soundbar as
well I mean paired together these are a
must-have if you love watching movies if
you love watching any kind of TV show
with great sound great image quality
that's the gist of this video we're
going to dive a little bit deeper into
this because this TV also has some
gaming uh features to it which I think a
lot of you will like especially if you
have a PS5 which you probably do already
have and it pairs beautifully with that
we'll talk more about that in just a
second but right now let's talk about
the aadl in all its Glory all right
first let's talk about the aadl in terms
of the feature specs that I have now
this is an upgrade from the a80k from
last year there is a different processor
in it it's supposed to be a little bit
better in terms of color rendition and
image quality a little bit sharper the
colors look a little bit better but it's
not a huge difference but it's the
overall
um performance of the TV that I think is
going to really impress you first and
foremost I mean the blacks are great the
one thing about Sony TVs as you all know
they do come at a premium but they also
do deliver a really good image quality
to a great blacks great contrast
um in terms of the highlights and the
Shadows there's a really nice roll off
to it so it looks a very natural at the
same time and it's not so harsh and
Stark as some of the other less
expensive TVs out there can look
especially when you're dealing with
various different
um images from let's say Netflix or
Disney Plus or whatever I may have you
um that's one thing I like about the
Sony TVs for the most part now this TV
right here in terms of the design of it
it's relatively simple as most Sony TVs
are it's pretty much image quality
that's it the bezels on this are quite
slim it says quite of a slim TV for the
most part except for the very back of it
where you can have obviously your HDMI
ports and your various different ports
in for audio and for video but on the
outside of it around that area is
relatively thin now it is a heavy TV to
sort of set up so you're definitely
going to want two people to do this with
you so I especially for a 77 inch I know
this is probably something I don't need
to tell you but I'm just putting it out
there this is a heavier setup so make
sure that you have the right uh the
right wall mount on this and make sure
you have someone that can also help you
make it sure that you don't drop the TV
it's very expensive here in Singapore
this is running for around 10 grand
Singapore dollars roughly around 7000
USD for this setup for the TV alone the
sound bar we'll talk about in just a
second that is a premium Soundbar 7.1.2
uh Dolby Atmos Channel this is a very
very good sound bar and it pairs
beautifully with us especially if you're
watching movies Okay so let's talk about
this the menu system from Sony is pretty
much part and parcel what we've already
seen for before out of the other Sony
TVs it's very user friendly very easy to
set up and it's quite fast I mean when
you start when you turn on the TV at the
very beginning there will be a little
bit of a hiccup for it to kind of get
just get warmed up and once it does
there's no sort of stuttering or
jittering I mean all the windows just
move as you want is it you want them to
be accessing your quick menu system is
there going from bid to standard
different picture profiles the cinema to
IMAX that's all there part and parcel
what we've already seen from Sony TVs
already now for me I let's like to set
either at standard if I'm watching
YouTube or I like to go Cinema and now
some people like to set it up at Vivid
and I'm coming out of the box it does
come out as Vivid but the Vivid on this
is not as Vivid as I've seen from other
TVs out there it has a nice rich color
saturated but it's not overly saturated
so you may find yourself happy with
Vivid if you're watching a lot of
YouTubers streaming content might be
like hey this is good enough for me and
that's fine now of course you can micro
adjust the picture quality like you can
on any other um all that TV out there
and you can really fine tune it and I
would say experiment with that if you
want to go into that direction but
really out of the box the settings that
Sony already has kind of preset for you
are relatively really good and that's
the thing I like about Sony TVs is fuss
free once you set it up with your Google
account it is an Android TV you get that
up and running you set the picture you
want the audio HDMI ARC for let's say
the Sony Sound Bar here
you're ready to watch uh content in
minutes it's that simple obviously you
have Google assistant on this so you can
you know talk to your TV if you want to
do certain things like that it's all
built into this so in that aspect it's
like every other Android TV what you're
getting for this TV is the picture
quality and also for gaming because once
you turn on your PS5 there is a separate
menu system that pops up for gaming
which you can you can get into various
different settings if you want your
variable refresh rate all that kind of
stuff that this will automatically work
with you on especially if you want 4K
gaming content you want the best picture
quality possible that menu system that
pops up automatically is going to enable
you to do that very quickly without
having to like doing a deep dive into
other systems or Sub menu systems inside
of a television I mean that's one of the
benefits of owning a PS5 and a Sony TV
as they are going to work together and
that's what Sony has done with the a80l
especially in that regard but um overall
I like it the speakers out of this TV
are relatively good without a sound bar
I have to tell you I mean Sony's done a
really good job job in terms of their
Sound Performance out of their TVs for a
number of years already it gives you
sort of that cinematic feel with the
speakers sort of coming out from the
screen which gives you that Vibe of that
you're in a cinema now the sound out of
the TV is great but if you want a better
sounding experience we got to talk about
the sound bar before we do that here's a
quick message from today's sponsor he
here at geek culture we've tested plenty
of chairs but Secret Life gaming chairs
remain one of our favorites whether it's
for work or play they feel great to lean
back against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head
and back
to the arms and even something for your
butt this mix of Form and Function helps
the Titan Evo 2020 to deliver the best
seating experience like no other for
more information check out secretlab.co
when you do pair it with a very good
sound bar system the HTA 7000 things are
going to change dramatically for the
better let's talk about that right now
now the HTA 7000 is one of their premium
sound bars here it is a very quite a
large sound bar as you can see
underneath this TV here this is a 77
inch TV and it's almost I mean I don't
have it exactly centered because I got
my PS5 right here but you're going to
notice that this sound bar is Hefty it's
got a lot of weight but it has a lot of
speakers they fire up they fire out and
there's subwoofers in this as well so
this gives you a very good 3D sound in
your room now currently in my home setup
here I run boats right so I have two uh
speakers in the back I have a subwoofer
and I have my my sound bar that I
normally have set up on day to day but I
found with the HTS seven thousand
that with this 3D sound effect that they
created with Sony's done with this I'm
not missing my rear speakers I'm not
missing that extra subwoofer yeah good
bass is nice to have but if you're
living in a condo or if you're living in
an apartment where you don't want to
upset your neighbors something like the
sound bar might come in handy versus a
dedicated sound woofer that's going to
just boom you're going to hear a lot of
bass and Rumble the floor you don't get
that with this but it's a nice solid
base that just gives a nice Dimension to
your image especially if you're watching
movies or gaming it sounds fantastic now
this does come at a premium okay and
there's a lot of various different
settings you can go inside of this it
also has Google Assistant as well but
look the whole idea behind this system
or at least for me personally is you
want something that you can plug it in
you start up it syncs automatically you
don't need to think about it HDMI art is
inside of this you plug in with the via
HDMI cable into the TV it automatically
recognizes each other you turn it on it
is on there's no Delay from The Sound
Bar turning on with the TV it just
automatically syncs and it's you don't
have to think about it and that's the
whole idea behind it if you want to dive
deeper into the menu settings you can
but you don't need to do it with this
and that's the thing that I love about
it in terms of the design it's got some
fabric on the top various different
black materials a gloss black on the top
of it as well to give it more of a Luxe
feel more of a higher end feel and of
course you have the speaker Grille on
the front of it here now with the area
we're here with the fabric is at is
actually speakers that are shooting up
to this part of the TV Screw coming up
out and you get this whole immersive
sound effect with that so with this it
also simulates the speaker the sound
coming through the screen like you would
get out of a Sony television already or
like you would get out of a movie
theater but it kind of emulates that
with that sort of a projection so it's
it's quite interesting to hear it um you
do all you notice is that it just sounds
more rounder and that's essentially the
HTA 7000 in a nutshell it's a premium
sound bar but if you have the means to
afford it along with the aadl you're
going to be very very happy now are
there any cons with this TV that I found
or anything call into the sound bar
um look with the Soundbar I mean you do
get a little bit of an LED uh sort of
text readout when you're navigating
through it it's not the most
user-friendly thing I mean I wish there
was more of a you could just put a whole
display there and just kind of swipe
through what you want to do it's not
necessarily that kind of that sound bar
maybe they'll do that in the future so
that's probably would be a con if I was
to knock it on anything but that's a
slight con the audio performance is
there in terms of the TV is the
brightness of it I mean most OLED TVs
aren't necessarily that bright but this
one is one of those that you'll notice
especially if you're gonna be watching
TV daytime like for example in this room
if you're having a natural sunlight
coming into your room like this even at
its brightest setting it may not be
bright enough for you now if you're in a
controlled lighting environment let's
say your bedroom and your curtains are
closed or it's nighttime no issues at
all with that or if your family room or
living room wherever you're going to put
your TV at but if you are going to be
watching this let's say at uh yeah
natural sunlight coming right into your
room sometimes it's a little bit hard to
see the image as clearly as you would
want it to be I mean not a deal breaker
but again most people have curtains in
the room anyway you just kind of close
the curds and you watch it but uh at
night time no issues it's great
experience especially watching TV in bed
another thing that I like on this TV is
the smooth gradation aspect on this now
what this is is basically sometimes when
you're looking at say sunsets or
sunrises or a halo effect especially on
Disney Plus for example that's a prime
example we'll show you when they have
the Disney plus logo you see sort of
those lines that go around the light to
the dark area with the smooth gradation
it will reduce that to give it a much
more of a natural nuanced gradation as
it was supposed to look one of the good
things I like about it just enhances the
picture overall especially when you're
watching streaming content because
sometimes depending on your signal or
depending on your connection may not be
the best image quality coming out and
this can help just more sort of smoothen
out those artifacts and make it look a
little bit better all right and outside
of that
um yeah I mean there's a lot of settings
you can play with inside this TV to
really fine tune your image but the
basics are there if you want more
detailed more intricate settings that
are in there like any other OLED TV but
it is what Sony's done with their TVs
here that I've really really enjoyed and
uh
overall though in a nutshell this is my
favorite Sony TV that I've used to date
in terms of I mean if you're comparing
cost image quality uh features that it
has I've really really enjoyed this and
yeah I'm a fan just wish it wasn't 10
000 Singapore dollars which was a little
bit less just a bit so I could afford it
otherwise it is what it is anyway goes
back to Sony after this review but big
thanks to Sony Singapore I'm not paid
our sponsor for this by the way my
thoughts my thoughts only and if you
guys like this video check out more of
our TV reviews right here
foreign